I've been doing this job for over a
decade I have seen a lot of dangerous
sensationalized Wellness claims on this
app but what probably upsets me even
more is seeing hyper-restrictive content
disguised as intuitive eating
anti-dieting or Ed recovery tips and
this stuff is sneaky as well because
these content creators share these
beautiful Bountiful meals and snacks and
they talk about self-love and they talk
about fueling their body with what feels
good to it which are all things that we
talk about here as well but to me The
Telltale sign of a piece of content that
is co-opting the intuitive eating
movement and dangerously luring in
vulnerable Edie populations into a
potentially new Ed is the body checks
intuitive eating at its core rejects
diet mentality but when a video kicks
off with Unapologetic body checks or
before and after body shots it is very
clear that this content is not about
intuitive eating or self-care it's about
manipulating your body through
self-control